so we've been following at sky news uh
the saga for the last few days
of who paid for the refurbishment of
number 11. boris johnson and kerry simon
his fiancee's private
flat it's been very little information
put by them in
the public domain if it comes from a
donor then that could potentially be
illegal
if those donations weren't properly
declared we've just had
a statement from the electoral
commission it says we have been in
contact with the conservative party
since late march and have conducted an
assessment of the information they have
provided to us
we are now satisfied that there are
reasonable grounds to suspect that an
offence
or offences may have occurred we will
therefore continue
this work as a formal investigation to
establish whether or not this is the
case
the investigation will determine whether
any transactions
relating to the works on 11 downing
street fall within the regime regulated
by the commission
whether such funding was reported as
required we will provide an update once
the investigation is complete we will
not be commenting
further on upon this point
now this is all about the 58
000 pounds that the public purse
wouldn't meet when it came to
the refurbishment of the number 11 flat
uh
carrie simons boris johnson understood
to have used a high-end designer
uh who favors fancy wallpaper the bills
were spiraling
we know from our reporting others
reporting
that lots of options on how to fund this
were considered
including donors donors contributing to
blind trusts but the problem for the
prime minister is that this
work took place at the beginning of 2020
and here we are at the end of april 2021
and nothing has appeared in public
registers
in accordance with the rules you've got
about a month to declare
any donations either people paying you
cash directly or giving you services in
kind none of that has appeared on the
public purse and it remains today
entirely unclear how the 58 000 pounds
has been funded because we know that
while boris johnson we were told last
friday
footed that bill we also understand he
took a loan it's not clear where that
money come from came from either
or who paid the in the interim between
the works being done
and the moment when uh boris johnson
reimbursed
uh uh whoever was footing the bill until
that and and to be clear
if the conservative party or
conservative party donors
paid initially for uh
the renovations or if that wasn't
declared
which would actually be the offense well
it depends what the electoral commission
judges as the recipient of the dhoni
which may well be the prime minister
himself because it was his
personal redecoration that seems to be
at the heart of this
issue uh some liability could fall on
the conservative party uh themselves if
they did not
uh declare donations there is an email
leaked to the daily mail last week
suggesting that lord brownlow a tory
donor gave 58 000 pounds to the party
for the purposes of
setting up this trust but that doesn't
appear to a cl appear it doesn't appear
anywhere on any public register and we
don't know why
uh that's the case um so there are a
whole slew of questions for all of the
actors in this
we also know because sky news revealed
this last night that last july
uh number 10 officials were in broad all
of this contacting alice to darling
trying to set up
a trust but he uh stayed well away
thinking that there could be something a
bit dodgy about it and of course we're
not at that stage yet but what sanctions
does the electoral commission have in
its uh remit
well the electoral commission which
doesn't have a great track record of
actually
getting through to either finding or
prosecuting uh
uh individuals or or parties and and
making those um
uh stick has a range of fines and
possibly
uh more criminal sanction but they are
very very rare and that will be defining
what on the parties or well we would we
wait to see but um
boris johnson is regulated under the uh
uh
you know 2000 elections uh donations
rules and so theoretically it could be
him or it could be the party or it could
be other individual actors
uh depending on what their role was the
the
what the electoral commission is looking
at here is the failure to declare money
and that could be the conservative party
it could be boris johnson
because of the worries that that could
come with an attempt to influence
political decision making honours lists
and and receipt of money
to renovate a private flat would that be
an offence uh
well potentially if you are in receipt
you know if a donor paid a contractor
uh to sort of um you know make you make
your flat look nice
that's a donation in kind donations need
to be recorded uh within a month and
failure to do so is potentially a
criminal offence so
yes downing street all the way along and
the conservative party say no laws have
been broken